a double-double for John good ball
movement there by the Mavericks got a
good shot from Dantas for a young that's
a two-pointer
because I didn't want to get that good
foul ground much you could do a section
inside garage and scores is he used his
body against Butler
six left down to went down
[Music]
back to Luca was seven now on the shot
clock
watch Donovan jump on him in the corner
hi Chris done right here seasons got the
advantage I watch the double come right
there but he still was able to get
through we're gonna pick our lineup so
nice backdoor cut by Conley in a pitch
out Karen Jackson
holy cow what up finish from the
youngster see the Grizzlies here good
job backdoor cut by Colleen because of
the cut draws the defenders nobody there
and her Nana Gomes a brief attempt at
this monster is slant firt or Smith is
right with him sets him up Maui on a
free throw line jumper Jordan making
space for Luca they see me rolling
DeAndre Jordan from Luca uh-huh he's so
good at drawing two times there's two
guys clearly on him and it's so easy
here nice drop off and he just takes
brazen raid that Jordan he's attacking
his feet and that's what you've got to
do you don't want to play a length and
strength game but with the rebound
bubier Dutch look up
box slams at home of a feat from Moody's
you first missing this quarter for
Minnesota's 305 now
[Applause]
nice pass out Allen drives takes a big
step inside on the kick-out to Dante
what an assist by the ball up top he
really sees the floor very well
most impaired it is why your jets and a
block by Baba magic running Ross hits
the three the old favorites going down
here's Trey off a drive twisting and
scoring and a beautiful move up three
this time sex is gonna hurry here goes
the clock hits it up nine one one call
for college safe he's got six
there are combined over eight
what a pass by Zach Lavine that play as
well again not lauded for his defense
does have two steals tonight cappella
ahead of the field block by Jaron great
was covered the best cappella with model
Jenna trailing three bangle always
looking for open and cool here he is
driving finds it up in person the
DeAndre Jordan
rolling hot to Doug look at his super
happy he's able to finish one of these
dogs
excellent path
Melton on the drive lines eight
[Applause]
got it
the Hornets on fire from their town 7 of
10 from three-point range and knocks it
to three at the buzzer
Bagley Koufos Bogdanovich and Barrowman
Marvin
nice pass instead of shooting that
basketball I would say probably a couple
weeks ago in his shotty he finds Costa
right underneath
35:31 lead Grayson Allen with a quick
hitter it's nice to see after he misses
first two to stay with the confident
shot trying to get Terrence Ross his
Papa choose any Isaac and bomba with the
Bob 10 off the bench he wasn't starting
lineup but lasting off the day just 459
3 Devon with the flush nice set up by
Trey there's nowhere to go in trouble
bounce Sexton he's gonna have to fire
kind of sexy with the 11 trying to get
around pity
watch it kill shows off his rip
protecting